only trees that are flawless make the
grade as a source of veneer products
this walnut tree from Slovakia is not up
to standard it's too old we didn't know
that at first you couldn't see it from
the outside it looked nice while it was
standing but here you can see that this
ring goes all the way through
manufacturing veneer is a risky business
buyers are looking for large flawless
surfaces each sheet is only six tenths
of a millimeter thick the Shonan grow
company buys trees from around the world
this mahogany wood comes from Ghana
last year the German government banned
the import of illegally harvested wood
in an effort to clamp down on illegal
logging now every tree has to be
certified for import the importer has to
give us a guarantee or we can't buy it
and this one's guaranteed the market for
veneer has contracted by more than 50%
in recent years many firms have gone out
of business as customers opt for
synthetic products cheap alternatives
are a challenge for us we can't just
give away a natural product that took a
hundred years to grow in the forest
that's not possible or sustainable so we
have to fight against this trend by
marketing what is something valuable
refined and expensive that's no longer
available in your average furniture
store it's simply too costly to produce
shorn and grow also procures veneer wood
from the nearby Black Forest company
boss Aqsa Grove says cutting down older
trees does no harm it's a sensible way
to keep this forest healthy removing the
bigger trees gives the smaller ones room
to grow
an average 48 million cubic meters of
wood are harvested in Germany each year
and lumber prices have remained high
since the 2008 financial crisis